I'm involved with everything you know um
you know it doesn't nothing passes me
without my input and my collaboration
which I've always had input on all the
shoes and this is no different I think
we tried to make the best technical
basketball shoe that we could got a name
for it
Air Jordan
I don't know
seriously maybe it'll grow on me but at
the same time we try to make the best
stylish basketball shoot in coordination
to what the consumer wanted some of the
kids as well as some of the adults now
Michael is this the shoe and of course
we can't show what kind of shoe this is
that's okay the color stamp but is this
the shoe that the NBA wouldn't let you
wear now why wouldn't they let you wear
it just just because it's ugly
feel very thankful that uh
for all the things I've done on the
basketball court and for all the things
I've tried to do with the shoe product
and athletic wear that we've done that
so many of people have come from
different fields and backgrounds and
athletic and entertainment and music
it's a great appreciation that what I've
done over my 15 years of playing the
game of basketball and that you've come
together in respect and certainly
supportive what we are trying to do with
the Jordan brand and you know it means a
lot to us we will continue to try to
make a product that you guys hold true
to a certain style and certain attitude
that you connect with
do you know how I get up for my game do
you know do you know do you know that's
right Air Jordan Air Jordan Air Jordan
it's a different different feel for me
to do commercials and to see people
enjoy those situations uh it's kind of
fun
making my living one day I don't know I
don't think I can put up with the hours
but it was fun doing them with Spike Lee
and Nike and I think the relationship is
building and it's going to continue to
build so it was fun and it's great to
see the
the work appreciate it I've been very
fortunate to get involved with him right
with people that have been able to help
me mold a certain image and get involved
with businesses and come on Michael it's
game time get your hands on lace up your
Nikes grab your Wheaties and your
Gatorade we'll pick up a Big Mac on the
way to the ballpark I've always tried to
maintain a connection with
the real world you know and not
isolating myself away I think once you
isolate yourself away then you become
more of a mistinctive person and and
probably more
more pursued to understand more about
that and being that I can interact with
society and be able to move around and
they can see me more regularly instead
of a rarity I've been very successful in
trying to maintain this positive
Vibes that I've done or created on the
basketball court well
something aside from that once I step
off the basketball court and this is an
expansion of that and this is an
awareness that I want to bring to the
Forefront so that you have a better
rounded picture about Michael Jordan
[Music]
foreign